be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
[Music]
[Applause]
so our previous discussion on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with regards to the
pre-twentieth century seem to be quite
well-received you guys really seem to
enjoy this idea because what I did
what's filling the gaps it made a lot of
sense of the things that we're going on
in relation to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for the Marvel hadn't really
shown us in the films that they had
basically explained across different
forms of media but what we were able to
do was basically consolidate all this
information into one video and so that's
what we're gonna do here but this time
it's gonna be a little bit different
with a nineteenth-century there's a lot
of things that go on there are a lot of
things that take place where I guess
with the 20th century there's a lot of
things that take place and so because of
that what we're gonna do is we're gonna
split this into decades we're gonna go
with the 19th the late 1920s in the
early 1930s we're gonna go with the
1940s and 50s and 60s and so on until we
are basically caught up with the events
as they're unfolding in the in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now what we do
here again starting with the late 1920s
is we pick up with uh with Steve Rogers
know a lot of the information that we're
gonna be getting here coming from the
early 1930s or I guess the pre World War
2 era and going into World War 2 are
gonna come from Captain America first
vengeance which were basically the comic
book tie-ins
to the Captain America film but what we
know is that at the end of the 1920s
that Steve Rogers father had already
been killed he of course was a soldier
and Steve Rogers father being a soldier
had really inspired him to become a
soldier himself but more so than that to
basically speak out against any kind of
wrongdoings to really develop this
incredible moral compass in terms of
what he believes is right and wrong but
again the problem is that's going on
here with Steve Rogers is that he's a
very a very small child
he's a very just has a very small
stature in relation to where he should
be if that makes any sense and so what
happens here is a Steve Rogers mother is
apparently dying and so what we do is
again we jump forward a little bit here
and what we find is a Steve Rogers again
standing up for what he believes to be
right is in a fight with some
local children are some local law kids
who apparently run this kind of 10th
Street gang I guess is what it would be
in the in the late 1920s and of course
what they're telling Steve Rogers is
that he has to pay some kind of a toll
here but of course Steve Rogers turns us
down and says he won't have anything to
do with it and continues to fight now
this is when we see Steve Rogers and
Bucky Barnes meet for the first time and
the reason why is because Bucky Barnes
basically intervenes on behalf of Steve
Rogers and helps to fight off these
bullies which of course they run away
and the two of them begin to shake hands
and meet with one another in Steve
Rogers tells us that he's a orphan now
that his mother has already died at this
point in time and so again this begins
to form this close friendship the two of
them will have going into their
adulthood and especially in World War
two now what we also do is we kind of go
back and we jump into the idea of Johann
Schmidt and Abraham Erskine now what we
have to do here is really kind of
reference Captain America the First
Avenger this is really the only
information we get here now what we know
is that again with around 1930 or so
that Abraham Erskine began working on
the Super Soldier Serum now we don't
really know why this had been done we
didn't really know exactly what got him
into this all we know is that he's
simply just begun doing it because again
this entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
takes place separately from the
earth-616 continuity and so Abraham
Erskine's entire a mind set for forming
the Super Soldier Serum and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe may very well be
entirely different from what we had seen
in the earth-616 continuity but the fact
remains is that by 1930 Abraham Erskine
was working on this project now what we
also do here is we switch to 1934 and
1934 is when things really begin to pick
up for a Johann Schmidt as well as a
Nazi Germany and even going forward into
the the Hydra science division and what
happens here is there some kind of a
play that's taking place and with them
once this play actually comes to an end
once this opera is over that Johann
Schmidt meets with Adolf Hitler and
Ernest Kaufman now Ernest Kaufman is the
head of the Nazi Germany science
division or I guess the special weapons
division that is referred to here and
what happens is Johann Schmidt begins
speaking with Adolf Hitler and what he
tells Adolf Hitler is that the old
stories the stories are the old gods of
Thor of Odin and so on that these tales
of incredible magic and things like that
may not necessarily be myths
there may be truth to this and so again
Adolf Hitler here seems intrigued by
what it is at Johann Schmidt is saying
and so what he tells Ernest Kaufman is
to basically create time so a meeting
can take place between Adolf Hitler and
Johann Schmidt but of course once Adolph
Hitler leaves Ernst Kaufman turns
against Johann Schmidt he throws him out
of the building and tells him never to a
contact Adolph Hitler again otherwise
under Schmidt will have them killed and
so what happens here is that as that
Johann Schmidt meets with with Heinrich
Himmler and Heinrich Himmler effectively
takes Johann Schmidt under his wing
which makes Johann Schmidt a member of
the SS now again what happens here as we
continue with this is that ultimately we
see that this really kind of comes to a
head the relationship between or I guess
the conflict between Johann Schmidt and
Ernst Kaufman when we see an event
taking place called the night of the
Long Knives
now the medve Long Knives was a real
world event it took place during during
Nazi Germany and for those of you guys
who don't know about this the night of
the Long Knives was a situation whereby
Germany had the head of the Browncoats
killed and what had happened was as
Germany I guess is a Nazi that IC party
was rising to a prominence and Nazi
Germany as they were beginning to take
over popularity in Germany what they
were doing is they were achieving this
by basically a strong-arming people that
whenever the Nazi Party had public
speakings
that anyone who came out and spoke
against the Nazi Party would be thrown
out by the Browncoats the Browncoats
would intimidate businessmen and
business business women to supporting
Nazi Germany it was different different
situations that were taking place where
the Braun Costra basically hired thugs
and so once the Nazi Party had seized
control of Germany there was no more
need for the Browncoats but more so than
that the Browncoats were your average
men an average woman they were various
people here and there and the problem
was that it would have been very very
easy for the Browncoats
to spur public aport against Nazi
Germany and so what would happen is that
Nazi Germany would be stuck in this kind
of a rock and a hard place and so what
what happened is they had the heads of
the Browncoats killed and the Browncoats
were basically a non-existent they kind
of fell apart and and really went away
at this point and so what happens here
is Johann Schmidt uses the event of the
night of the Long Knives as an excuse to
effectively kill Ernest Kaufmann but of
course he arrives at the home of Ernest
Kaufmann telling him that all his
comrades are dead and when Ernest
Kaufmann is killed Johann Schmidt
takes over the science division and this
ultimately leads to the eventual
formation of Hydra in terms of the
entire Nazi science group now from here
what we also do is that we see that
Johann Schmidt eventually invades one of
the weapons depots or one of the testing
grounds for four Kaufman's former
science division and when he does he
encounters a man named Arnim Zola and
Arnim Zola again we know him to be the I
guess the henchman so to speak of a
hunch Schmidt from Captain America where
Captain America the First Avenger but
what was happening here as Arnim Zola
was working on a kind of exoskeleton
suit he was working on a suit that would
allow one man to function as a robot
basically a very early version of what
we would later on see as the Iron Man
armor but the idea here was that this
person would be able to operate as a
battalion as Arnim Zola says rather than
a person fighting as one man alongside a
multitude of other people this suit
would allow him to take on a whole host
of forces by himself and then if enough
people have this armor they could
effectively have a much smaller group of
people taking out a much larger group of
people and so when Johann Schmidt says
is that all of the the resources the
entire budget of Arnim Zola is going to
be focused on this one project and his
goal is to enhance on this project to
make it better and to also improve it to
allow more suits to be made now for me
here what we do is we jump to 1935 and
with 1935 what we see is that Abraham
Erskine who again had previously been
working on the Super Soldier Serum tries
to leave Germany now as he's leaving
Germany what we find is that apparently
Johann Schmidt has somehow heard about
what it was that Abraham Erskine was
working on and so Abraham were Abraham
Erskine as he's hearing about these
different laws the the rumors of laws
that will be passed against the Jewish
people attempting to leave with his
family realizes that various soldiers
have arrived on the train in which they
are taking and the soldiers are going
around with a picture basically asking
anybody if they'd seen this man who is
Abraham Erskine and so what Abraham
Erskine does is he tells his wife that
nobody else should do it should suffer
on his behalf and so what happens here
is the children I guess the the children
of the wife and son of a Abraham Erskine
are sent off to a concentration camp and
Abraham Erskine is a taken by Johann
Schmidt and forced it basically were due
for their work on the Super Soldier
Serum which of course we know will
eventually lead into you
becoming the Red Skull when the Super
Soldier Serum is used on him with that
being said this pretty much brings an
end to the entire idea of the xxx or I'm
sorry the 1930s brings an end to the
this period of time what we'll do in the
next video is we'll pick up by the 1940s
as we get into the 1940s we'll see that
once World War Two is kicking off now
things will continue to again move at a
very fast pace with that being said
we're going to and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]
Oh